this is a beautiful story we kind of
want to wrap things up on this there's a
there was this was a uh manhunt
this is uh
this is a tale as old as time a
corrections officer falls in love with a
inmate
they escape together this is one of the
old the only american real love stories
we have left you know
there's a few love stories we have left
in this country
you know what i mean we have a country
of morbidly obese fentanyl addicts and
child nazis
that's our country like prepubescent
nazis
morbidly obese fentanyl addicts
and like like like
so in our country when you think of the
configurations in which people find and
love each other you have the uh
teacher student
you have the
uh
powerful business guy uh
perhaps underage prostitute
you have
maybe two closeted nazis that are
[ __ ]
whatever but
what really encapsulates it because we
so many people in america are in uh jail
in prison
so many
and there should be
more no
so many people
are in prison and are incarcerated for
all manner of different things for
non-violent drug offenses for very
violent offenses
and they're in prison and then we have
corrections officers who are essentially
criminals corrections officers and
criminals there's very little difference
but no this is true there's very little
difference between corrections officers
and criminals most people that get into
corrections are criminals or would have
been criminals or our criminals they run
like teen fight clubs in the jails
they they uh they sneak in drugs and
stuff it's their oh they're like
prostitutes too
yeah they [ __ ] them and everything and i
have no issue with all that but whatever
it gets you through the day it makes
everybody happy i believe in communities
i believe in communities i love that
uh
so
this is a great story about a female
corrections officer right
who fell in love with a guy who's uh
they're trying to get him for murder
yeah yeah yeah pin him they're trying to
pin him
another innocent john
is this the woman that spent like she
like sold her home and used the money to
bail him this will sum it up real quick
it's great she shot herself story about
a jailhouse romance that ended in death
a veteran corrections officer apparently
fell in love with an inmate and helped
him escape with her so that
that the two of them could run off
together it happened at the lauderdale
county jail in alabama authorities say
the 38 year old inmate casey white who
was awaiting trial on murder struck up a
relationship with 56 year old vicki
white no relation she was the assistant
director of corrections at the jail
where he was incarcerated her co-workers
described her as an exemplary employee
but that's right you say she planned how
to get casey out here by the way let's
make a point that is an exemplary
employee if you're a corrections officer
yeah
breaking them out of jail and [ __ ]
them
that like that is an exemplary employee
because here's the deal you're around
them all the time you're gonna fall in
love with them
yeah it's true you're gonna fall in love
with these p look at this guy you're
telling me you're not gonna fall in love
with this guy neanderthal jon hamm
the fact that this guy murdered somebody
turns you on it makes you hot
you know this guy killed someone
and and i lock his cage every night and
i let him out man what a fantasy
i lock his cage and then i let him out
it's hot
and she lives in alabama and she looks
like she's like an albino [ __ ]
you know
i don't know mole rat
[Laughter]
we all have to pretend like alex because
all these political people now have to
pretend that like new york and l.a suck
because they they listen we all know
taxes are high and like liberals can be
crazy like everybody has to pretend like
that's what america is about it's like
alabama
everybody has to pretend that they're
like i won't live in missouri
it's
he said guys you realize
bill maher had a great joke years ago he
said if it wasn't new york in l.a the
country would have been sold to china
years ago
like there is no but everybody has to
pretend like politically i've never been
to a place and went you know what i love
here the political uh outlook
i've never looked at an ocean and went i
love the taxes here
just allow yourself to have another
experience on the planet you [ __ ]
monkeys
but people can't do it right they can't
so they everything's political i don't
say austin's a [ __ ] because it's a
blue city in a red state or a purple i
say it's a shittle because it's a
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] it's hot it's
muggy there's bugs the food's gross the
rivers are [ __ ] they're brown they look
like literal [ __ ] they're disgusting the
people are disgusting they're
unaccomplished they're idiots that's why
i say [ __ ] it's nothing to do with the
politics i don't know what the laws are
i don't care dump
i go to santa barbara i go it's pretty
but yeah there's homeless to the laws of
nuts and the people that run it are
[ __ ] psychopaths it doesn't mean it
ain't a better place to live all things
being equal
like if we let's say you gave taxes in
florida a state tax and a hefty one
you know how many people really love it
how many people are down there with
[ __ ] cowboy hats and boots like yeah
[Applause]
if you love it like let's see if you
would pay for it you wouldn't pay for it
right no there's nothing to pay for it
might listen with all the respect i like
dallas i like some places great
audiences but you go around austin you
go yeah i wouldn't pay a state tax to
live here why would i why would anyone
why would anyone pay estate tax so they
could take the boat out on the [ __ ]
river
it's gross
and i'm sorry
palm beach isn't palm beach doesn't have
a state tax either right malibu is is
kind of a dump but it's better than
austin the the hamptons better than
austin
lake lanier in georgia better than
austin
charlotte
charleston south carolina better you
know i don't know i don't know if
charleston's a democratic city or
republican city i don't care
doesn't mean anything to me but people
right now are so invested in politics
because it gives their meaningless lives
some type of like shape that they can
understand like you're good
because they have nothing going on in
their [ __ ] lives
and i understand that there's real
concerns and now they're trying to
get rid of roe v wade and [ __ ] like that
i'm not saying it's completely
unimportant but to make it this entire
thing where
you have to lie to yourself and start
saying that like
lake austin's nice can you get get up
lake austin and we'll get back to these
two retards but get up a photo of lake
austin get up a photo of lake
and hit image
go to the right right there it is it's a
level from donkey kong
that is a level from donkey kong it is
slime it's green slime from donkey kong
now get up a picture of malibu
california
and i i i don't like gavin newsom but
just get a picture of mount blue
california
it's better
don't you get that it's it's better
that's nicer and that ain't even that
nice
malibu ain't even that great it's not
even that good but it's better than that
swamp where i can shoot maggots in
[Applause]
[Music]
no
so whatever but
there's nothing in malibu that looks
like that they just lie with some [ __ ]
too yeah it doesn't look like that
another [ __ ] it doesn't look like
that's like italian
malibu's like a dump but the point is
it's a nicer dump everything on earth is
a dump
we just went to the rain forest it's
fake
the great barrier reef doesn't exist we
put cigarettes out on it it's a
everything's a dump
but my point is don't get with the
politics it annoys me when you have to
start lying you start to start lying and
be like
i love you and these are people from the
northeast or from the west coast and
they go down there and they're like yep
[Applause]
all these tech demons these autistic
[ __ ] blinking tech [ __ ] and
they're like
[Music]
it's [ __ ]
grotesque
whatever we have fans there it's a nice
place
let's finish up these two retards
she even sold her home and announced her
retirement beforehand then on april 29th
authorities say vicki picked up casey
from the jail for what she said was a
mental health evaluation which
authorities later learned was never even
scheduled the two of them fled in her
patrol car
vicki had spent the night before in a
motel near the jail authorities say she
bought men's clothing from a department
store beforehand so that casey would
have something to change into nice after
they left the jail the two of them
ditched her patrol car in a parking lot
where cops later found her jail keys a
radio and handcuffs
then they went on the run for 11 days
on next 11 days of their lives
the manager of a car wash in evansville
indiana had spotted casey on
surveillance video why are they washing
a car
oh good question how stupid are you
why are you washing your car they're
like we don't want people to think we're
dirty
why are you washing or is he maybe he's
hanging out there to rob people like why
are you you're on the run
where are they running where's the
destination who knows but why would you
stop in a car wash
i don't know yeah maybe they think they
run they were getting tailed so they
pulled in or something i don't know well
let's finish it all right here we go
they called federal authorities
yes marshall service called me that's
right they sent me a text message from
alabama
this is this guy
when tech guys moved to austin texas
that all went to stamford
this is what they sound like
after three months in austin keep going
truck
told i said i did i said that's a guy
from alabama he said yes it is
so he said i got us monsters coming to
you even as i speak
cops located the pair pretty quickly and
saw vicki walking out of a motel with a
wig on
then they chased the pair down the
pursuit ended with the police crashing
into their getaway car they were able to
pull casey out of the wreckage but they
say vicki was critically hurt she had
shot herself in the head she later died
at the hospital
as for casey soon he'll be on his way
back to alabama he was already serving a
75-year sentence
by the dawn's early light
what so
proudly we hailed as the twilight's last
streaming
whose broad stripes and bright stars
through the
perilous night
gave proof i don't even know if i'm
doing this right
that our flag was still there
and the rock is red glare
vicki's head bursting in there gave
proof
i mean what a beautiful story
victor shot herself in the head she got
a wheat she got a week of that good dick
what a whirlwind for the convict he's
just being taken back to prison like oh
that was weird
[Music]
but here's the deal it's true love and
when you know it you know it right folks
i mean when you know it you know it and
when it hits you you don't always choose
you don't always choose it
she found someone that that loved her
and saw her for her
yeah and
he was a murderer
and
she ended up being a murderer she killed
herself
isn't that fun
but it's an american story they should
make that a film
yeah that should be a film yeah you know
yeah like somebody that loves that
deeply where they go i'm just gonna blow
my brains out because i can't face the
thought of everyone at the old job where
i had authority being like what the [ __ ]
you cause she turned on her family yeah
you know
it's not like la where by doing that
you're rewarded with houses and pools
and tennis courts
they're in [ __ ] canvil
the only thing this woman has is those
those other mongoloids that she works
with and they all drink coffee together
and they beat the inmates and they lock
them up
and that's what she does and she turned
on them
by taking one of these inmates out
escaping
putting the rest of the cops in danger
and
wouldn't it be funny if they didn't even
[ __ ] she's like i'm waiting for
he's marriage we gotta [ __ ] you and i'm
telling you they're gonna get us and
she's like no
we're gonna live we got our whole lives
wouldn't it be funny if that was her
attitude she's like we got our whole
lives for this
he's like i don't think so
he's like please let's just [ __ ]
she's like we got our whole life she's
picking she's on zillow she's like what
can we afford he's like listen
i think you're underestimating how deep
of [ __ ] we're in they're gonna come get
us and i'm going back to jail
it says here i can get approved for 185
000
with a down pipe now you can't go on the
loan of course but with a down payment i
can get something nice we can get a
double wide
man you know what's nice i hear is
austin texas
cause joe rogan's
he's opening a comedy club down there in
austin texas and elon musk's gonna let
us say hard r on twitter
so let's go to texas
and he's like honey i think we're gonna
get shot some guy made me at the [ __ ]
car wash
well
that's where i wash my [ __ ]
you really shouldn't have done kill tony
tonight yeah wearing a lot of [ __ ]
i thought you were funny your minute was
good
honey you made me do that i tend to
think that really that that really
exposed us now you were good
uh but it's an american it's a beautiful
american love story
and there's not much like that anymore
and you know it's it's uh that intensity
of love no it'll be a mini series soon
it should be right on hulu someone else
kind of like selman louise a little bit
yeah a little bit bonnie and clyde
especially at transcen's age she was 56
he was 38. yeah but they're going to
give it it's going to be hot people it
needs to yeah it'll be charlize their
own no it needs to be gross people where
the sex scenes make you go ugh
but it should be like really gross like
that's what
movies need like gross sex scenes again
where like it's just real animalistic
disgusting
like she has an open wound yeah you know
when it smells because it's moldy
and you could tell like he's flinching
as he enters her
and she's like and she makes this little
sound like
[Music]
she's got a light parking sensor she
shakes as he does it she's like
[Music]
that's what it should be
and and then like the last scene in the
movie he's like they're [ __ ] getting
us he's like i'll always love you and he
goes in for a kiss and before before he
gets to her she goes like this she goes
you
know you know and then they're like
dedicated to the legacy of the civil
rights march
like something that has nothing to do
something has nothing to do with
anything
you know
produced by colin kaepernick
produced by the obamas